anyone who thinks that anybody has to be  in Austin where else can you choose  between more than 2,000 live acts for  more than 50 countries a lot of them are  hoping a kick here could be the big  break through  but these guys are already legends  public enemy one of the highlights so  far  this event at the German house is  celebrating 30 years of South by  Southwest and is a bit of a time trip  krautrock is on the agenda the movement  had its roots in the 70s Faust and  Kraftwerk where the pioneers but it's  enjoying some think of a renaissance and  there are new bands like stabile elite  coming through all the time  but the thing that really makes south by  southwest is what's happening on every  street corner there are parties and  performances everywhere there are plenty  of fairly eccentric personalities and  every conceivable musical genre